a defining moment that started a 12-year
journey is Qatar
Qatar winning the right to host the
World Cup
[Applause]
the country has since undertaken one of
the most ambitious construction of force
in world history
building eight stadiums equipped with
sophisticated technology and dozens of
other Advanced sporting facilities
multi-lane roads now cross the capital
Doha and it's connected by a high-tech
Metro system with driverless trains
the infrastructure has allowed Qatar to
jump at light speed
completing changes infrastructural
changes that would take other countries
decades upon decades we see Metro
stations we see massive motorways we see
more modern I suppose medical
infrastructure facilities that we can
use as residents of this country beyond
the tournament
but through it all cutter face
challenges in June 2017 four Arab
countries imposed an air Land and Sea
blockade on the country
that was lifted in 2021 when the
pandemic broke out
but with covid-19 stolen supplies of
Labor and materials Qatar faced more
pressure to reach its 2022 deadline
it also introduced labor reforms
ensuring all employees received a
minimum wage any script is sponsorship
system known as cafella to allow migrant
workers to change jobs without needing
their employers consent
since winning the rights to host the
World Cup Qatar has showcased its major
development projects for the tournament
and is also taking this opportunity to
turn its capital Doha into a worldwide
cultural social and educational Hub
reflecting the heritage and life of the
region
Education City now hosts eight
prestigious International universities
and new museums and libraries preserve
the history of the country and the
region
with expats comprising more than
two-thirds of its population Qatar has
created many green spaces and social and
entertainment facilities
a bigger strategy in terms of you know
modernizing the country developing its
infrastructure capabilities and even
just kind of putting it on the map so to
speak in terms of it being not just
obviously a hub of of Natural Resources
you know as a one of the biggest gas
exporters in the world but thinking
about it also in terms of a cultural Hub
with the construction of its schools and
museums and you know Film Institute and
all kinds of other array of cultural
institutions
Qatar says the World Cup is not the end
of the journey under its Qatar National
Vision 2030 it aims to sustain its
transformation
starting with the final world
championships for Aquatics and Asia's
Premier Soccer Tournament the Asian cup
next year
Al Jazeera Doha